so we've been playing uh
a lot of clips from this from this
hearing
from the bad guys
and i don't mean to oversimplify it but
i mean it really is that simple they're
just they they're the bad guys and when
when this is what you're you're standing
for and this is what you're this is what
you're enraged about is that we're going
to be killing fewer babies then you're
that's the bad guy side and there's a
very clear line that we can draw there
so we played some of the bad guy eclipse
there's one other clip i wanted to play
for and i'm saving it for here
because representative burgess owens
he's on the good side
he uh in the midst of all of this lunacy
he interjected with
i'm trying to stop myself from using the
phrase truth bombs because i hate that
phrase
but i'll allow it here just this one
time it's the only time you'll ever hear
me say it
because i think these really are if
anything qualifies as a truth bomb then
then this actually is listen to what he
has to say
i think we're gonna ever get to
resolving the issues we're having in in
the black community we gotta be honest
my friends
uh we just heard that uh
a pushback on the fact that we're
getting black men and black community
not doing their job well let me give you
the facts real quick first of all
when i was growing up in the 60s we led
the country and then committed to
marriage over 70 percent
black women could could rely on getting
married more than white men until white
women until 1970. we now have between 70
to 80 percent of black fathers who
deserve their families and we're not
willing to be honest about that
we're not willing to say that these
these guys need to man up
maybe when we start telling
when we start telling our our kids
that they're being nothing but whiners
wings and wimps if men cannot take care
of their own kids that might be a good
start i ain't rejecting the words
mr chairman i call for orders
we right now the facts are here it's the
big says the time the facts are in facts
black fathers
70 to 80 percent are deserting their
families to talk to talk these black
single women out there and see what they
think about this we see this little
bubble
where we're living the life
we were married many of us
and we cannot be honest about what's
happening in our urban communities
while these kids are growing up with no
followers no solutions at the end of the
day there's a reason why our kids are
being
led toward these this these options of
hopelessness
and for us to sit here and 2021 no not
right now i'm sorry let me just finish
to sit here in 2021
and not point out the fact that we have
fatherless homes
we have seventy to eighty percent these
are the facts my friends
seven eighty percent will not marry the
mothers of their children and instead
would probably try to convince them so
to dissolve them from their issues to go
and get an abortion
we've lost 20 million black babies over
the last 40 years 40
of my race has been exterminated
because we don't have men
yeah i want i wanted to play as much of
that clip as i could it wasn't even the
whole the whole thing goes on for
another few minutes and uh i i think
it's i think it's great it it two things
are great about it and very instructive
and revealing
uh
the one is what he's saying but also you
hear the woman i'm not even sure which
which congresswoman that is but
frantically trying to cut in it's i
object to this language that's being
used
he actually says well we got to take
responsibility to care for our families
i object to that language this is
offensive i can't believe what's being
said
can i can i are you finished can i could
i just
they're they're so terrified to have
that coverage they don't want to have
this conversation at all
about taking responsibility for yourself
and your own families
they don't want to talk about the state
of the family
in the black community and across the
country
and how that ties into
all of our problems every single problem
that we're having societally speaking
every single one
can be traced
uh in large part back to the collapse of
the family
this is no great secret
and it shouldn't require any courage to
point it out
and i shouldn't be so impressed that
there's a
someone in congress making this point
because it's so obvious
you you can't have a society
without the family
you know we've got we've got thousands
of years
of history to look at
with human civilization
and we can look out throughout the world
throughout history every single
civilization that's ever existed on the
planet every human civilization
and there's never been one
that has tried to do it without the
family structure at the foundation of it
it can't happen you can't do it
because that that is that is the
fundamental building block for for
everything else everything else rests
upon the family
and if you abandon the family
there's there's nothing else that can
come in and sufficiently
take its place
that's the experiment that we are
conducting right now
especially in the cities
can we get rid of the family say we
don't need the family and have the
government come in and and uh and take
over that responsibility you know we
don't need we don't need fathers to be
the breadwinners and the providers and
the protectors the government could we
can do that we can put them on the
social programs and put them on the
welfare programs
um and we you know we have a bunch of
cops there and and you know so we will
fill out with provider protector we fill
all those roles
as the government
so we have watched this
experiment
play out in the cities for decades
and to put it mildly it has not worked
i mean it's been a catastrophe it has
been an apocalyptic catastrophe
that's why when you walk through cities
today it looks like a literal
apocalyptic wasteland you're walking
through
and all that you're seeing there that is
the debris
of the nuclear family which has
collapsed
in the cities and also across the
country increasingly
fatherless homes are a problem
uh across the country people are
abandoning marriage abandoning nuclear
family i mean this is this is a social
trend
that you find everywhere
um
now
the fact that this is happening and the
consequences of it
are inescapable
and the democrats know that and so
they're they're only
there's nothing they could say in
response to it
so instead they just try to ignore it
and they they always deflect and say no
let's look over there look at that no no
no we don't need to talk about let's
talk about guns let's let's talk if
there's if there are you know young men
in the cities running around shooting
each other for no reason
uh let's talk about how they got to hand
their hands on those guns that's the
problem
let's not discuss
why those young men would want to behave
that way in the first place what went so
horribly wrong
in their upbringing in their home lives
that if they have guns they're just
going to go out and shoot each other for
no reason
let's not talk about that part of it no
no let's just discuss the gun so that's
what democrats want to do and if someone
sits there especially some burgers owen
burgess owens a black man uh if if he
sits there and talks about this they get
very angry and they they don't want to
discuss it and that tells you everything
you need to know
in fact at one point i think she
actually said she said something like
well what are your solutions you're not
you're not coming up with any solutions
yeah he is
he gave the solution
that's the solution was
take fathers take care of your families
you know when you have kids
get married preferably before you have
the kids
um
but worst case after if that's what if
that's what you need to do
and uh and then and and and stay with
your kids and raise them that's the
solution
have kids
a woman and man have kids they stay in
the same house
and they raise those kids
that's the solution
if you're saying well give us a solution
besides that
let's not do that and think of a
different solution there isn't one there
is no other solution there is no plan b
because they've been looking for a plan
b for decades and they haven't found one
so if we're giving up on the family then
we're then we just we've given up on
society we've given up on civilization
there's no point of even talking about
any of this stuff just forget about it
there's no point
we've given up
let it all collapse and we'll we'll all
live in the ruins i guess
if you want a real solution
it has to begin there yeah there are
other things we can do
it's not like if we have a strong
nuclear family in in america that we're
going to live in a utopia there's still
going to be other problems we have to
fix but we've got to start there
have kids stay at home with them
if we're ruling that out if you're not
going to do that then
then there's no hope then we we are
hopeless at that point
so it's this or it's nothing
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated